I do freestyle rap so that's made up
it's not written it's not prepared it's
based on your suggestion so you the
audience get to one person of their twin
yes which is rarely the response when a
white British man says
it's the first time that's ever happened
everyone else was doing the normal
response of oh dear and and you went yes
which is some type of masochist over
there we'll take five suggestions then
we'll drop a beat to a three-star app
we'll divide you guys up so everyone
gets a fair go if you are sat in this
section here what would you like to hear
a freestyle rap about
you said croquet oh how quaint
um have you ever played croquet
why did you say yeah as if
you have a stalker my friend I hate to
inform you
um so you said obviously yes I don't I
don't think that's obvious what I can't
imagine that really crossing the
Atlantic is this a did you play over
here
why why did you keep saying obviously to
questions that are not it's not um
everyone else here just thinks you're
mispronouncing Cricket hey
no idea okay wow so you where did you
where did you play croquet
how do you have a yard what this is New
York City you're just there like aha yes
my palatial grabs where do you live
you lived in Kansas oh so you have all
literally just like [__] kick the
corn out the way
let's play croquet okay
croquet croquet may be croquet in Kansas
let's let's bounce over to this side of
the room hello this side of the room
um what would you like to hear a rap
about number two
okay there were two
we'll focus on the one that wasn't
Israel Palestine first
Napoleon Dynamite okay
um great
and Israel Palestine
um
Napoleon Dynamite in Israel Palestine
croquet in Kansas uh I guess kind of
front of the middle of the room what
would you like a rapper
[Applause]
Israel versus Palestine apparently we
can yes with this
um okay fine Jesus [__] Christ should
we should we just stick with the croquet
no don't worry don't worry okay so back
up back up what did you say
it sounds like very quietly a very
giggly lady is saying micropenis is that
yeah
I hope it's a suggestion and not a
Heckle madam
[Laughter]
not wearing such tight trousers
okay so so far it's Napoleon Dynamite in
Israel Palestine Roe v Wade micro penis
croquet and at the back of the room
someone you were saying something before
a lady whispered micropenis what was it
so
[__] it's all the men in the room you
have no idea what this is but it as
zenpick is the the skinny drug right
that it turns out for the past two and a
half years every celebrity in La has
been getting these injections
essentially it makes you repulsed by
even thought of food it makes you
nauseated it's it's so [__] cheeky
that they can it's unfair really like
I'm upset but okay
um a Zen pick although it goes under
other names well with Govi or something
as well okay so the skinny drug and then
the back you said cremation which okay
usually only take five suggestions but
I'm gonna take an extra because I fear
that Roe v Wade and Israel Palestine are
probably gonna be quite short bits of
the wrap
okay well the other things to remind you
micropenis and uh croquet a zenpick
yes don't yeah we remember micro penis
someone just enjoying saying micropenis
in a public space well my lovely band
are going to provide us with a musical
backing that I I I'm always excited to
see what it is they I make the wrap up
they make the music up so let's uh let's
put these things together and have some
fun
oh Soulful red here's micro penis and
he's like yeah we need something kind of
you know a little bit jaunty a little
bit Jazzy it's uh it's gonna be good
it's all made up based on your
suggestions if you don't like the wrap
it's your fault you should have picked
better things but um okay cool
the Middle East West Frank cars why the
guys trying to fight let me solve it
with the problem Napoleon Dynamite Vault
for Pedro taking that chance he'd be
United in the Palestinians and Israelis
doing dances the whole history if you've
never seen it success is a mystery it's
like a slightly low-fi Indie comedy I
don't remember last time I watched it
properly usually I'm stoned they're in
my home when I say stoned I don't mean
the ones that get thrown into
settlements from people on the other
side look you don't like it why you
acting so snide if we think way back
it's out of order it's mainly the
British because we drew the Border we
were like ah yes this suits you I can't
see this causing problems in the future
but right now people ever so dismayed
getting upset like it's Roe v Wade maybe
six months ago that [__] was banned
going out to the states in this land and
now 12 different places are passing the
law trying to get rid of me for Prestone
to be sure that you can't get abortions
if you're in a red straight use a condom
maybe get your head straight otherwise
you gotta go and do it in the back alley
with the little coat hanger I don't mean
to provoke any anger you said croquet
they didn't understand you you take a
mallet and then you [__] hit it Crow
case felt very differently to Cricket
but it's still got the same thing hooray
takes a long time you can sit there all
day nicely on the lawn iced tea in your
palm if you're from Kansas third time's
the charm get rid of stalks of corn and
then yes hit it through the tiny little
legs and the gates if you've seen Alice
in Wonderland then you'll know get a
hedgehog and a flamingo and just hit it
starts to roll you know what I mean
they're on the green with the evil queen
she be upset she's kind of fat no need
to offended Queen maybe slim down get a
Zen pick insert that every month then
all the weight just falls off it shunts
down there you're like who's telling me
I'm reducing my intake of all the
calories no need for for these yes I can
scream this last thing [__] hell
micro penis I can't believe that you
shouted that you were like yeah I've got
a really small [__] so I need a small
dick to match it up maybe one inch one
and a half that's the cut off point for
me I need to reverse the drug if they
had a fattening one that chubs it up I
put it in that's the opposite as them
pick but actually if you've got a small
one don't be offended when you die no
one will know if they bury you actually
your dick could be on show so this is
the answer no hesitation if you've got a
micro penis then ask for cremation
thank you